[Music]
hey I'm so visa lazy this is Kelsea
Ballerini hi guys and in the spirit of
her debut albums the first time we are
going to bring you a little segment
called healthy salary knees first time
here's how it's going to work we're
going to take a little trip down memory
lane I am going to ask you about a first
and you are going to tell me all about
what you remember from that moment
correct ready let's start with the first
time you hit a red carpet it was the
American country countdown Awards the
first one of those okay in Nashville I
wasn't actually allowed to walk the
carpet yet because my single I think yes
I have a top 40 or something so I was a
correspondent for Radio Disney all the
red carpet so I was like on the other
side of the barricade and our viewing
artist so I could be at the carpet so I
could just feel like I was a part of it
I want to just take a little flashback
to the first time I met you that was at
the 50th ACM yes I remember on the red
carpet yes it was so awesome it was like
a corseted top and just like kind of
high-low skirt that I wore and the
corset ties were like really long and
they fell all the toilet the first time
you shot a music video it was in
Nashville is for my single love me like
you mean it it was like February when we
kinda shot it was freezing and my legs
were like purple since they were so cold
so in between takes it was paint to my
legs so they looked normal because it
was so breathing
[Music]
now I know you have a kind of probably a
two-part story to this one but I when I
was the first time you met Taylor Swift
not as a fan though she had texted me
right after after she tweeted about my
record was insane and she was hosting a
birthday party for her friend abigail at
her place in Nashville and invited me
and just like ran up and hugged me and
like grabbed my hand brought me into her
apartment introduced me to like all of
her friends like hailey from Paramore
and Kings of Leon all these no big deal
yeah and I was like okay I am just
leaning on them and so she was she was
so lovely those the first time I met her
like artisanal what about the first time
you stepped out on stage for the 1989
tour oh god I was so nervous I was so
nervous
and I just remember being down below the
stage you can still see the upper like
rim of the arena and so I was being I
was down there and I was looking up and
she was announcing me and I was like oh
like it's gonna go up and I can't get
off like I can't get off now
and I just started going up and I said
oh oh gosh and and then you just are up
there you see the whole arena full of
people and it was hectic it was amazing
I got home that night and I was laying
in bed and she posted the picture of me
and her from that night on her Instagram
I lived at it and I'm told it was the
first time it actually hit me like what
had happened that night
[Applause]
[Music]
so what about the first time you stepped
out on your own headlining tour oh gosh
that's were so fun it was it was I was
nervous but I was more like comfortable
because it was people that knew my songs
knew my music not just the singles but
the whole record
I was nervous about more excited when is
the first time you knew you had made it
in country music I'll let you know I'll
let you know no I have moments of like
oh this is pretty cool but I don't I've
never had a moment where I'm like man
I'm like killing it or like man I
deserve to be here at like I'm still
beaming that I get to you know be in the
running with people that I've looked up
to my whole life so I found out this
morning that I am nominated for Best New
Artist at Grammys the Grammys the first
time you were nominated for Christmas I
just happened
um I woke up to my phone just buzzing
off the hook and I knew the nominations
were coming out and I was like I really
wanted it like that's probably not okay
for me to say but like I really wanted
it what for honestly I read and and so I
knew like we might go sorta go and I was
like this is good or bad news and I love
the notes it was really good news yeah
you're like I don't know if you can see
this she's like welling up a little
nervous ha ha I love it well this one
might ready let's do it the first time
you met your fiancé okay well he have a
different story but he interviewed me
like a year before we and we don't
remember I don't remember him I remember
our first time meeting was in Australia
last March and we hosted be CMC Awards
together and everyone says that we want
to afterparty whole demands and I don't
doubt it does he say when he tells that
story about the first time he met you
did he say that it was love at first
sight no yeah he always jokes that he
had my CDs we could prepare for the
interview and he was strutting around
with his best friend and
because I got into my wife a listening
this happy / now we're hearing that's a
keeper hi I'm so excited yeah
I'm trying to cool but don't make any
harm within your arms
[Music]
all right in the spirit of Kelsey's
first we are here doing something with
her for the very first time you have
never been to the iconic Griffith
Observatory I have never been here so
here we are we took a field trip this is
so worth it it's so beautiful Hollywood
sign is right there Hollywood's not have
you ever been that close eye hollows I
have not I I've heard that it's highly
illegal like it's kind of it you look
out this way it's crazy views did you
ever see yourself living here okay I
think I'll end up having a like maybe an
apartment or something yeah like my
parents both lived in California for a
bit of their lives I think it's kind of
like in my blood of it and imagine all
the time anyway so might as well just
sound like a little home and I'll make
one day away from hollandaise oh thank
you so much for coming up here and let's
go take some selfies I'm getting
incredible
[Music]